[موسيقى]
قفزه النجم يوسف النصاري التاريخيه لحظات
تسجيله هدف فوز المنتخب المغربي على نظيره
البرتغالي اثار التفاعل عشاق ومتابعي كره
القدم متسائرين ما اذا كان نصيري قد حطم
الرقم القياسي المسجل باسم كريستيانو
رونالدو الموقع الرسمي لدوره الالعاب
الاولمبيه يذكر ان اعلى قفزه بلغت مترين و
93 سم وهي مسجله باسم رونالدو وذلك عندما
احرز هدفا لريال مدريد في مرمى مانشستر
يونايتد في دوري ابطال اوروبا عام 2013
قفزه النصير وصلت لمترين و 78 سم ما يعني
انه لم يتخطى رونالدو الذي ظل محتفظا
برقمه القياسي لكن نصيري كسر الرقم
القياسي الثانيه المقدر بن مترين 62 سم
المسجل باسم اللاعب الاوغندي عن هدفه
لنادي مذرويل في مرمى روستونتي ضمن
منافسات الدوري الاسكتلندي عام 2001 2020